Welcome. Raf, also co author on the
paper. So how are you doing?
I'm good. What about you? Pretty good.
Other than this brief interval of white
light, I'm just hanging out.
Fantastic. So I'm trying to figure out
here how I can. I'm using a different
slide software, so I need to make sure
that I can pull this up in the right
way. So give me just a quick second.
Yeah, great. Cool. So just just to
read off what's coming while you figure
that out.
So right now we have Ralph Kaufman, and
this presentation is going to be Gaia,
an active powered network for planetary
scale sense making. Following this 30
minutes presentation, we'll have Avel
Gwynen Carlo on embedded Normativity.
That looks perfect. That's perfect.
Awesome. All right. Thanks, Raph, to
you. Thank you. All right, I was going
to try to see if I could blow this up to
full screen, but.
I got it on the stream.
Looks good on the stream. Go for it.
Cool. So I'm just pulling up my notes
here. All right, so let
me just test that this moves. Did I
just move the slide?
Great. Cool. All right, so as I said,
hi, everyone. It's a huge pleasure to be
here and thank you so much to Daniel and
everybody else in the Institute for
organizing this. I'm going to talk about
what I think is the single most
important application of active
entrance. Not as a detriment to the
others, but it's sort of upstream of
everything else. And that is how do the
8 billion of us humans make sense of
what's going on in our planet and all
scales? And how do we use that
understanding to survive as a species?
So this presentation here is a bit of a
technical presentation and it has a lot
of content. It's going to move pretty
fast and assume that you're familiar
with some concepts, but I'm going to try
to leave time for Q A at the end. So
first of all, I'm going to talk about
the motivation behind what we're doing,
in particular the concepts of the meta
crisis and the third attractor. Then
I'll give an overview of our network
architecture and the application so far
and cover the many remaining challenges.
And last but not least, I plan to
convince you that this is the single
most important thing you could ever be
working on. And I'm doing this because
we need your help. So that's a taster of
what we have. As I said,
let's jump right into it with the
motivation. And what greater motivation
could there be? If you haven't heard of
the metacrisis, it's a term that it's
originally from Doctor Who, but it was
borrowed by thinker called Daniel
Schmuckenberger to talk about the total
risk for humanity and the biosphere that
is posed by the combination of three
factors. The first being the increasing
interconnectedness of everything from
climate to food security to national
security. To biodiversity and everything
in between. The second being the risks
associated with self evolving
technology, including runaway artificial
intelligence and the third being the
increasing omnipresence of coordination
failures personified as the god of
coordination failures moloch. And so the
combination of these three factors as
hypothesized by Schmuckenberger will
lead to either one of two attractors,
one of them being chaotic breakdown of
all structure and the second being a
reversal to oppressive authoritarian
control. And obviously both of those
qualify as that in my book, I assume in
yours as well. So the question of course
is can we actually find a third
attractor that is positive sum as
opposed to negative sum? And rather the
question is can we design it? So what I
claim, and what we as the Guy Consortium
claim, is that yes we can and we can
design this attractor. The design
goal is basically to build resilience
and stabilization into our biosocial
economic system and to do this subject
to multilevel system constraints like
the planetary boundaries desirability,
meaning it has to be something that
people actually want so they will help
it happen. So it needs to preserve
standards of living and so on. And it
needs to be feasible, it needs to be
achievable from our current initial
conditions. And of course there's a lot
of design complicators in the mix, some
of which partial observation, there's a
lot of information asymmetry going on,
there's a lot of uncertainty about how
the pieces of the world system work from
a scientific perspective, there's
obvious computability constraints
associated to this. And last but not
least, you can't really control what
happens. In most cases we can only
create incentives, recommendations and
nudges. So easy,
right? Of course it's not easy, but we
think we can do it if we apply the sum
of the principles from cybernetics that
we already know and apply them in a
decentralized positive sum composable
way. So what we're talking about here is
decentralized network, a decentralized
hybrid AI human network for planetary
scale decision support and automation.
It recognizes that we will have human
and artificial agents interacting by the
billions in an open network. Its goal is
to facilitate both continuance or model
alignment and coherence or goal
alignment at multiple levels or scales
up to the global scale, meaning the
survival of the system as a whole. It
will need to feature built in incentives
and governance and it will need to be
privacy preserving, intrinsically. So
the below listed participants are
participants, founders of the
consortium. I'm going to talk about it
later. So this is the framing,
this is the motivation for what we're
doing. And now I'm going to give a
whirlwind tour of the architecture so
far and I'm going to cover mostly what
we've built, the version of this
architecture that we've built so far,
thinking about this explicitly. And then
I'm going to talk about how this
connects to other architectures that
already exist in the world, just very
briefly. So we've been framing this
as an architecture for building
decentralized digital twins, which are
local models of real world systems that
run in network. And the role
that such digital twins play is that
they help us understand the costs and
benefits of strategies and projects that
happen in the real world. And in
our organization, Digital Gaia, we
started out caring primarily about
agroecology. So how do you actually make
better decisions, meaning better
recommendations, negotiations,
valuations, investments into a farm,
into a forest, into bio
landscape, to make it better, to make it
more likely to survive and thrive.
So, as practical implementation,
it needs to tackle several real world
challenges. First of all, it needs to
handle distributed, non IID data.
Data is sparse. It's heterogeneous,
it's private, it's potentially
unreliable. It needs to enable localized
collaborative forecasting and planning,
personalized planning and privacy
preserving. It needs to accept
the fact that it won't be able to
directly control, but only recommended
nudge, as we discussed. And the
outline of what we came up with is this
concept of the Guy Network, which is a
mesh of AI agents called natural
entities, or Ants for short, that act as
proxies for real world systems. Each ant
runs on an engine called Tengor, which
it uses to inquire, learn, plan, and
allocate resources. And ants communicate
in a language called the Guy Protocol.
They use this language to independently
interact with their environments and
each other. And if we do this right I'll
show a bit more of this later, but if we
do this right, the Guy network's
behavior approximates a single composite
agent that handles, that interacts
with and couples with its global
environment. Cool. So just
to give you an overview of how this
works under the hood, the Fangor engine
is really the heart of our architecture.
And the core loop that is mentioned here
is a typical active inference loop. But
to make this work in very heterogeneous
and distributed context, there's lots of
work involved. So just some highlights
that I think are going to be
particularly interesting for this crowd.
First of all, so as I said, the same
core engine needs to be able to work for
very heterogeneous contexts. So each
agent has access to a library of
generative models. And these models are
specified using a Python based
probabilistic programming DSL, and they
declare what context they're appropriate
for using a shared ontology. Using that
ontology, Fangorn can then select the
most appropriate model to use online,
given the configurations, like project
configurations and the kinds of
observational data available. So using
a model that's appropriate for farm
or for forest, what kind of farm, what
kind of forest, what kind of ecosystem,
what kind of their context energy
project I'm going to get into the
examples right now because there's more
on the applications later on. So we end
up with a network of heterogeneous
agents, but that's okay. They actually
form a single model in a formal sense
because they're all connected
hierarchically by a system of
hyperparators. And this means that
Fangor needs to support inference of
generic hierarchical generative models.
And we actually do this automatically
using approximate posteriors with
structural constraints.
And so we have this global model that
connects all the nodes and describes
general facts that apply over multiple
contexts. And this means the whole
network needs to jointly perform
inference over this global model using a
peer to peer or federated algorithm. So
initially the way this works is
initially the network sets the global
posterior to be the same as the global
prior. Each node then independently
performs local optimization of the
variational free energy and then passes
the parameters of the new global
solution to the peers in the network
where they use it as a hyperprior. And
this works over a broad range of
topologies and under pretty general
constraints. And by the way, I'd like to
mention that there's a lot of overlap
and interaction between the stuff that
I'm talking about here and some of the
other presentations that you're seeing
today and I wasn't able to reference
them explicitly in this talk, but I'm
sure you're going to see the connections
cool. So what it turns out is
that the shared parameters that
represent our global model are
effectively stored by the network stored
in a federated parameter store, meaning
that each node stores their own local
parameters, they're private stuffed
about their own local context and
multiple nodes store copies of the
global parameters. And this
architecture, because it supports
heterogeneous local models, it actually
allows us to introduce another kind of
nodes which we call ant mood nodes.
These are nodes that aggregate
scientific and empirical information
using a meta analysis model. And we
actually are able to use that meta
analysis model to constrain our project
level models or ants using quote unquote
imported knowledge that wasn't directly
observed by them, which is left to right
in this picture. But this actually also
goes two ways. So empirical findings
from the project, what actually works on
the ground for this particular project
also informs the ant modes posteriors
which is the right to left. And so we
actually have a complete cycle of
science and empirics all implemented
using hierarchical active inference.
So finally, just among the global
parameters that network learns by
federated inference are the precisions
associated with data coming from the
different data providers. And this gives
each node a way to consume data without
trusted ground truth and basically to
learn together which sources they can
rely on it for what? This is just some
of more core features. We're working on
integrating many other capabilities into
this architecture. Not going to go
through all of this, but basically what
we're finding is that we have all the
building blocks to turn this into a full
feature decision network complete with
its own internal knowledge economy,
meaning that contributions get
attributed and rewarded in proportion to
the free energy reduction that they
afford. Cool.
So, jumping into applications, as I
mentioned, our main focus as an
organization has been on modeling
agroecological projects like
regenerative agriculture and
agroforestry. And this exercises all the
constraints that we've talked about so
far. So again, I'm not going to go into
full detail, but just to give an
overview of what is the anatomy of
generative model for a farm or forest.
So start at the bottom right with
observables that are things that we can
measure about that ecosystem, about that
local context like the plant count and
size, vegetation indices from satellite
data and so on. These are linked
to latent states which form a nonlinear
dynamical system that's parameterized by
the policy the the things that
modulate the latent states like
agricultural interventions and
practices. You can think of the timing
of planting and harvesting, what kinds
of crops or trees get planted, what
products like pesticides get applied or
not, and more as well as covariates.
So external events like weather,
physical risks, wildfire, drought and so
on. And so there's some scientific
and measurement parameters that
go into this as well. Things like the
effect sizes of the various actions and
covariance. And these local parameters
are conditionally dependent on a set of
global parameters which, as we
discussed, they link information between
different ends and different sources of
knowledge.
The same global parameters are used in
the meta analysis model and they
actually establish the link between what
is found to happen on the ground and
what is reported in the literature.
I'm not going to go into this because I
think I'm going to run a bit long, but
basically the concept is that we have
these project nodes that correspond to
many farms and they're each on
independent nodes in the network that
are also connected to this common
metaanalysis model. And together
these nodes, they incorporate academic
studies, expert knowledge and locally
relevant context. They do so privately,
so only processing the local data
locally and through this parameter
sharing they actually jointly and
iteratively estimate the
global posterior in a cycle forever,
for as long as there is new data about
the project, as long as there's new
studies and new expert knowledges. So
all of this is happening basically in an
online way. And again, the topology can
vary, but the principles remain the
same. So, just to show a
little bit of how this works, this is
just two epochs of the global posteriors
and this is just location and scale for
two parameters the slope and the
intercept of the relationship between a
vegetation index and the tree biomass in
one given hectare of forest. And as
you can see, this converges pretty
quickly. It's comparable to local only
methods. And just to highlight how this
can be used, also the limits of how this
can be used to estimate source
reliability. Here's a really successful
example at the left. It's pretty
straightforward to use this to estimate
reliability of satellite
data. And for other cases, like very
local, very context specific data,
you actually need more data or more data
from more independent sources that we
had in this demo here.
Another very useful use case of this is,
as we discussed, we don't have direct
control over what happens at a form. We
can only recommend and nudge often. We
also like a node gets sued up,
gets sued up for an existing project
that has already happened and we want to
find out what actions were taken in the
past. And the same generative model can
be used to estimate what happened
in the past. In this example, it infers
when planting started and when harvests
started for different fields.
So bringing it all together. One of the
applications that we've been using,
we've been working on it actually uses
all this machinery together to validate
claims about projects performance and to
estimate future performance. We've
deployed this in real world projects.
The examples here in this photo are by
are relevant to Agroforestry farms in
Colombia. And we found that this
actually helps the project developers
and their funders to come to a shared
understanding of how successful the
project is, how much it's worth in terms
of its impact and its fundability,
whether it should be scaled up or needs
to change course. What is the quality of
the strategy versus other potential
strategies for natural regeneration and
so on? So it's actually useful
on the ground for decision making in
this context. Cool. So finally
I want to talk about the end state and
going back to our original motivation of
solving everything. I forgive you for
your thinking. This is nice. But hey,
we've been kind of in this downward
spiral towards the metacrisis for a long
time and what you're telling me doesn't
even come close to solving everything.
And you're right, there's a lot of
moving pieces that need to be built and
connected. But here's the good news. We
can do this. There's no mystery here and
we don't need perfection. I love this
quote from Edward Fulbrook that says
that to define a policy, we don't need
exact empirical measures or optimality,
if one jumps from an airplane, it may be
nice to have an ultimate, but what one
really needs is a parachute. So there is
only so much that we can get in terms of
diminishing returns. What we should be
refocusing on is creating and refining
solutions everywhere and connecting them
everywhere. And you might be thinking
about how does this actually scale to
global goals and how does this actually
get used for scalably building
into the fabric of decisions in our
society. So about scaling to global
goals, I again won't be able to get into
the details, but maybe Connor mentioned
this in his presentation earlier. We
have actually some proof of concepts
that we can actually build active agents
that are made of active agents.
So we've shown in this paper here that a
collective of interacting active agents
is able to perform approximate inference
at the ensemble level. And that this
further that this happens through
specific mechanisms that are mediated by
cognitive capabilities like theory of
mind and goal alignment. They work
together to improve collective
performance by eliminating ambiguity
through actively exploiting diversity.
So that's one. And the other question is
how do we actually build this kind of
stuff into not just these ad hoc
decisions, but into really the fabric of
decision making that is our global
economic system. So, talking about here
work that I did with Casper Hesp,
this is a game that highlights the
ability of ants just like the ones that
we just described to infer true system
state and use it to credibly incentivize
long term positive outcomes in an
externality happy scenario. This theme
we were able to show that it works even
with adversarial bot strategies and even
with high uncertainty and intentional
misinformation. So you can actually get
these ends to work with
budgets and incentives to drive decision
making that internalize externalities
and compensates for collusion and
generates long term positive outcomes.
That's not all. There are other
solutions that have been around for
longer than ours that apply similar
principles to global decision making
problems in the real world at scale.
This is one case study from our partners
at Cognizance that they developed for
the COVID pandemic and this is not
using Active infrastormalism. This is a
combination of traditional recurrent
neural networks for prediction and
evolutionary optimization for
prescription. And it's actually able to
achieve some pretty amazing stuff. It
discovers a pareto front between
prevention of cases and economic cost.
It's also a showcase for hybrid human AI
intelligence. They did an initial
version of this model, then they
launched an XPRIZE, they got a bunch of
contributions for other models and then
they did a meta model that discovered a
better pareto front and even better.
This tool has actually been used to
advise policy in the real world. So it's
actually very exciting that we're
working with them and connecting the
dots, because we need to connect the
dots, we need to bring it all together.
This illustration here is just, I think,
a subset of the effects of
the climate change crisis, which is just
one aspect of the metacrisis on
humans, on our society and the economy.
And so we actually need to be able to
deploy solutions that work across many
different domains and to connect these
dots. This means two things. The first
is interoperability aligning decisions
across context so that we don't get
unintended consequences. And second is
reusability so being able to transport
and transfer learning and structure
across contexts. So for instance, using
that evolutionary approach from the
COVID example in our agricultural
context or in many other possible
contexts, and this takes the form of
libraries, of components, APIs and so
forth. So that's what we're working on.
So we're launching this consortium. We
just put up the website a few minutes
ago, and we have the goal of having a
minimal but functionally complete
implementation by the end of next year.
And this is an open project. We are
working on this at our organization
called Digital Guy, but we're also
launching this open consortium that
welcomes contributors from anywhere,
both active inference experts and non
experts. And we need a lot
of contributors. We need all of you
because this is the most important thing
that we could ever be working on
together. And we need your help to
tackle the many remaining challenges.
So if you want to help us build the
planetary brain, please go to
Gaiaconsortium.org or reach out to me.
You know where to find me. And together
we can design, build, and learn what it
takes to achieve planetary regeneration.
Thank you.
Barath. Thanks for the great
presentation. I'll post the link
to Gaia Consortium into the YouTube
live chat. But let me get a few quick
questions in. So here we
go. First question. This is
from Marco Lynn.
I agree with the critical importance of
such a project. How will you deal with
the challenges of scaling given the
dependence on real world entities like
humans,
humans for major metacrisis domains such
as geopolitics, sociocultural
fragmentation, and other particularly
hard sense making domains?
First of all hi, Marco. Yeah, thanks for
the question. And I 100% agree that I'm
not claiming that this is sufficient.
I'm just claiming that it's necessary.
We do have a
lot of ideas and a lot of energy that we
want to put into exactly what you
described,
how to weave what we're doing into the
existing incentive landscapes, whether
they're market incentives or policy
incentives. But ultimately, this needs
to be an enabler. This needs to meet
people where they are. And we need to be
cognizant that change is not going to
happen overnight, at least not right
now. Right. Typically these things take
a while to mature and then they snap
into place. And we're already finding
some of this happening in some of the
domains that we're working on where
nothing happened for a very long time
and then bam, hockey stick. And we
believe that the same can happen pretty
much anywhere. So we're very optimistic.
Great. What are currently the greatest
challenges for Gaia as an organization?
I love that kind of ambiguous question,
like, is that the Gaia Consortium as an
organization or is it Gaia? But let's
hear both. What are the greatest
challenges or frictions for the
Consortium and for the bigger picture.
Going to I'm not going to talk about the
technical stuff for change. I'm going to
talk about the more meta stuff.
And it's actually very related to what
your previous presentation, Daniel,
about that paper about the Institute
talked about. And it's really related to
building out this common, what we were
calling the common cognitive kernel for
sense making and decision making and
relatedly breaking through this
culture of sort of suspicion and surf
wars and getting people trying
to stake their claim to something. So we
are, and always have been extremely
open, but it's kind of hard anyway to
build trust. So we're
aware that it's going to take a while to
build this trust with everybody. And I
think the only answer to that is really
to be as participatory and
transparent as possible. Also being
humble and knowing where
we don't have the answer and asking
people to help us.
Awesome. Any closing words or thoughts?
Well, if there are no further questions,
again, I thank you all for paying
attention and I'm going to be
reaching out a lot more. You're going to
hear a lot more about this consortium.
As I said, it was just formed. They just
put up a website in time for this
presentation. By the way, thanks so much
to Mahi and of course,
Steve and everybody else who's been part
of forming and getting this ball
to start rolling. We are very
early stage, very formative, and still
very client. So I
just gave you my perspective on a bunch
of these things, the shape of it that
has come from our work on this so far,
and even not all of it. Just a piece
that we could cover in 20 minutes or so.
But we are very plural.
We want to engage with you on
different paths, forward, different
opportunities to build things, to
experiment, to connect the dots, to
learn together. And ultimately,
we really just want to provide
a platform, a convening space, a
protocol in the classic sense of the
world, a word of a shared language, a
shared means of communication, a shared
means of understanding, to find together
what we need to do to actually build
this third attractor. Awesome call
Gaia trim tab. Thank you exactly.
Thanks so much, Daniel, and see you guys
soon. Bye bye.
All right.
What a cool presentation.